hello everyone I hope you're having an
excellent Saturday because we have a
game played by not one but actually two
hoody guys and mr. mister who today
would the white pieces this Christoph
Vanderloo and mr. hoodie guy would the
black pieces is mr. M hassling now this
game was played in a weekend tournament
in Holland in in 1983 now I don't really
know what a weekend
tournament in Holland this could be a
tournament played anywhere in Holland
over the weekend or it could be the name
of the tournament a weekend tournament I
couldn't find any information on this
but it's very interesting that as this
is one of the craziest games you will
most likely ever see we're gonna talk
about it some more after I show you the
actual game so as you roll I'm wearing
the hoodie to honor both hoodie guys
this time so let's just dive straight
into it
mister who the guy Christo Vanderloo
with the white pieces opens the game
with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6
we have Bishop to c4 Knight to f6 and
now comes the Knights the g5 so here the
most standard reply will be d5 who we've
seen this many times played and then
after for example d5 pawn chapters 95
and so on and so on you all pretty much
know this now but here we have a very
well a move that you will very rarely
see it's actually Bishop to c5 the
tracks or counter-attack by Karl Traxler
and it's it's really a wild opening
where a black really gives white a lot
of options you can capture with the
bishop on f7 you can capture with the
knight on f7 and the main line is the
capture with the night you could try
something like Bishop captures and then
after King moves let's say bring the
bishop back to protect the e4 pawn not
allow black to go for the usual tracks
the tracks lore ideas with Bishop
captures an f2 and Knight captures an e4
check but black wouldn't really have any
problem Syria after the knight is
captured pawn captures the Queen can
capture here and now you have a lot of
problems here as the Queen is already
attacking g2 so you can't really capture
the night and even d4 with an attack on
the Queen will be met with Queen
captures the rook is under attack and
now after rook moves Knight captures and
E
for now the night is saved the bishop is
saved with night coming to f3 white will
be lost so a very dangerous line if you
don't know what you're getting yourself
into but okay after Bishop to c5 we have
Knight captures on f7 this is the main
line
Bishop to f2 capturing King captures and
now comes the Knight captures on e4 so
this is still the the main line of the
night sacrifice and here if someone
plays this against you most likely you
will want to go King to g1 and then as
the black queen is under attack Queen h4
threatening checkmate here you will want
to play g3 and now after Knight captures
you don't want to recapture the night
because after Queen captures King f1
rook is coming to a fate pinning the
night and now you will not have a lot of
fun with white but what you can do after
Knight chapters and g3 you can snatch
the rook here and then after Knight
captures on h1 you can go d3 and then
the game continues you will have a very
nice game with white so after 94 we have
King - III not going to g1 but rather a
white decides to go for King to e3 and
here
Queen to e7 a very nice move because now
capturing the night with King characters
only four results in something like d5
check and after the bishop captures now
comes Queen to h4 with check King goes
back Queen d4 check King e2 and now
after Queen characters on d5 black will
have black will have a winning position
as White has no time to capture the rook
Bishop to g4 is a terrible threat here
so after Queen to e7 we have c3 and you
know look at the position this is only
move 7 we had Knights the d4 an
excellent move by black where if you
decide to capture this for example C
capture Sundy for you could you get it
capped or something for with check this
opens up the e-file and the white will
find himself in a lot of trouble so
after this night to d4 move we have King
captures on e4 going for the e night
instead Queen to h4 check King goes back
to e3 if you go king d5 then you get b6
and then there's really no defense
against Bishop to b7 so after Queen to
h4 King to e3 and now come
Queen to f4 check we have King to d3 and
here already we have an interesting
position where black if he wants to a
black and play Queen to a5 and settle
for a draw here it will be a draw a
perpetual check here I can just keep on
checking yet f5 f4 but after King to d3
we have d5 black is not at all
interested in a draw he has the white
king on d3 and he wants to finish this
game
we have Bishop Bishop captures on d5
with Bishop to f5 check and now King the
c4 so a very nice walk by the White King
beef I would check with King to c5 and
now comes Queen to h4 and here if you
play a silly move would White Queen to
h4 prepares a very deadly threat for
example if you capture the rope you get
Queen t7 checkmate
there's nowhere to go so of course it is
checkmate
so after Queen to h4 we have Knight
captures on e5 now Queen to F now Queen
to e7 check doesn't really do anything
as the pawn from e5 is no longer
guarding the night the King can simply
capture it and now after c5 check King
moves you will capture here but then
after King f2 Queen captures on d5 rupee
one check is coming and after the King
moves you can play d4 and after whitey
develops his pieces white will be up in
material and of course winning this game
so after Knight to e5 we have a very
nice queenside castle by black and here
again if you decide to play C captures
on d4 black actually has a forced
checkmate in six moves so as it is a
Saturday you know hopefully you have
some time feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this forced
checkmate checkmating sequence in 6
moves I will give you a couple of
seconds you know or as much as you want
because you can pause the video for you
to do it for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent user of your Saturday time and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show
rook captures on d5 is the move and now
if you capture then the other rock is
coming to d8 but now if the king moves
king before rook captures we have Knight
to c4 blocking or
you can run away with the king and get
made it even faster so you have to give
up a lot some of the pieces here rook
captures King to b5 now comes Bishop to
d7 check King f5 rook will be given but
it will come with a check made by the
Queen so Queen captures on a four will
be checkmate other plenty of checkmates
here this was the longest one because
white had to give up the most material
here so instead after the queenside
castle not capturing on d4 but rather we
have c4 here a very nice move by white
and now comes rock captures on d5 and
here C captures on d5 if you play King
captures on d5 then you are again
allowing black to go for rook to the 8th
check King c5 Queenie 7 again will be
checkmate so after rook to d5 we have C
capture Sun d5 and now comes Luke to d8
and here we have Knight to c3 just so
you know if white plays something like
rook to e1 it's very important to keep
an eye on the d5 pawn if you play
something like rook to e1 then you get
to 96 or Roe captors on d5 it either
will do now the Queen is controlling the
entire fourth rank the captures on e6
with Queen to d4 check King captures and
now again white will be checkmated with
Queen to c5 so after up to d8 we have
Knights the c3 a very important move
controlling the d5 pawn and here black
played Knight to c6 but it's very
important to show that night the e6
check doesn't work here like in the
previous variation because here after
wife captures that it would be alright
but here black can actually simply move
away with King chapters on b5 and now
there is no rope characters on d5 as the
knight is protecting the d5 pawn but one
move black could have played in after
this Knight to c3 move before the knight
see to remove after this rook to d8
now with Knight to c3 and now Knight to
c6 was played but instead of this Knight
to c6 black had Queen to f6 and now
there is really nothing to do for white
the thread is Queen to b6 and whatever
you do there is really not all that much
to be done here if
King captures than queen bee sucks will
again lead to the checkmate
so after Knight to c3 we have Knights
the c6 by black black now has a very
similar idea because the knight can be
captured with the pawn with the knight
or with the king so what happens if you
capture with the knife
if Knight captures then the simple pin
c4 will be checkmate
on the other hand if you capture with
the pawn if pawn captures then again
will have Queen d4 check King captures
and again will have this very nice
checkmating sequence Queen b6 check King
moves a rook checks King moves to a
three and now Queen to b4 will be
checkmate and lastly after this Knight
to c6 if we play rock in captures on c6
then we get Queen to b4 and again
there's no escaping checkmate here rook
to d6 is a threat that the bishop can
come to d7 simply too much threats it's
a mating 3 whatever white plays so after
this Knight to c6 move it seems like
there's really nothing white can do here
but there is one move white plate which
is basically why I'm showing you this
game on this very nice Saturday so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find it the move white plate here of
course I'll give you a couple of seconds
or as much as you want for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
this is truly a very interesting move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the move played in the
game was Queen to a4 offering a full
Queen here simply with the idea of after
this pawn captures the Queen the pawn
will no longer be controlling the c-4
square and after the knight captures the
Queen the C for checkmate will no longer
be available but if you found Queen to
g4 this actually also works because now
after Bishop you can't capture with the
Queen because the knight is guarding the
Queen but if Bishop captures then you
can capture here and now there's no
checkmate that the bishop is in the way
of the Queen to deliver checkmate and
the white will be still trying to wiggle
out of this but we will have a different
variation if Queen to g4 and Queen to f2
check will be played to d4 and then
after Mitchell characters on g4 you will
be able to capture on c6 and now
have this really weird position where
black is still better but white is white
is trying to hold on but like we said
after Knight to c6 Queen to a4 was
played and here if you capture the Queen
if B captures on a for tonight captures
on c6 it's black doesn't have any any
crushing moves that are doing anything
there's no point here to allow Queen to
c4 you can go Queen e7 check the knight
is controlling e7 the knight is also
threatening to capture an a7 would check
DeForest coming Bishop will come into
the game very soon so black also has to
be very careful here so black decided
not to capture the Queen would be
captured sorry B captures on a4 but
rather he went for Queen to e7 check
immediately and here okay if you play
something like d6 the block you are
getting check mated again Queen captures
King captures and now rook to d6 will be
checkmate
but after Queen to e7 check King capture
some beef I was played and here was a
blacks last hope
here black played Queen captures on e5
and now white simply gets too much what
black should have gone for is Knight
captures on e5 and now again White has
to make a move if you play something
like Queen to a6 check King b8 black is
threatening Bishop to d3 it's very hard
to parry this if King to a 4 then you
get rook to d6 attacking the Queen Queen
checks rogue blocks and after you move
the Queen now Queen to h4 check is
enough King to a 3 and now Knight to c4
check force the king and the Queen and
you can even make a little joke here by
not capturing the Queen was rather
Knight capture sound b2 I discovered to
check from the Queen and after the King
moves now Knight c4 check again King a 4
and now Bishop to see to checkmate as
there is no more beep on to block this
check but black did not go for this
rather black played the Queen captures
on e5 and here we have Queen to see for
a very strong move by white controlling
the d5 pawn black thought that okay if
white goes for something like Queen to
a6 chip King baton Queen c6 you know the
King is still quite loose here I'm gonna
try a lot of ideas
Bishop to d3 check I have Bishop to d7
winning the Queen so a lot of ideas here
that will still allow me to hunt the
white king but white is not greedy
instead why the ghost Queen to see for
simply keeping an eye on the d5 pawn and
now Knights the d4 Trek King has to move
we have Bishop to d7 check King to a5
and not night back to c6 check the pawn
cannot capture as its pinned but here we
have King to a6 nights the b8 check and
here white has to go back to a5 here
white captured an a7 and again we have a
very critical position where c6 was
played black thought that ok now there
is no defense against Queen to c7
checkmate but there was an even better
move because unfortunately for black c6
does not work as a white was able to
defend but there is one move here that
allows the mate in 5 and there is not
there is no way for black to stop it for
white to stop it so again feel free to
pause the video here as it is a Saturday
and find this with a very nice forcing
sequence for for black if you were able
to do it congratulations and if you've
solved this one and the previous 2 then
even bigger congratulations if you found
Queen to f6 that's very nice although
that's mating 9 if you found Queen to d6
then congratulations that truly is a
mate in 5 now you're threatening Queen
to b6 checkmate so and it's not all that
easy to prevent this if not a 4 you are
controlling the b6 square but now comes
Bishop captures again Queen b6 is the
threat of checkmate white and only
prolong it here you will give up the
Queen check King moves and now you are
getting check mated after any move
Bishop captures and c6 will be checkmate
or if you don't capture then the Queen
will checkmate on a 7 but still here
black thought it was the same idea here
black played c6 instead of Queen to d6
with the idea of coming here but now
white can actually prevent it with 9th
to b5 this was played in the game the
night is now controlling c7 and you
cannot capture the night because the
pawn is pinned so Bishop to a5 was
played by black and now comes
d4 with an attack on the Queen
black-white has enough time
look the 7 check we have King 2:8 and
now comes Queen to e7 here black is
hoping for some ideas if the rook moves
then somehow if the Queen comes to b7 it
will be checkmate
but white is simply too fast d captures
on c6 we have Bishop to e4 now pinning
the pawn but now d5 we have Bishop
captures on d5 and here white finally
decides to give up the Queen and here
black must accept but we have Queen
captures on d5 rook captures on d5 and
now Knight to a7 check again you have to
be very careful careful here so white
forces the black King to move we have
night to a7 check King moves and here
White has to play Bishop to f4 it's the
only good move for white but white again
makes a mistake and place King captures
on b8 and now again feel free to pause
the video here and try to find a winning
forcing sequence for black it's a mating
six so for the fourth time in this video
pause it and solve the position in the
game Queen to c7 check was played which
is not the way to go so if you found
Queen to b4 check congratulations you
are truly an excellent spender of
Saturday time now because here you have
to move you have to move into the corner
and now comes King to c7 you bring the
Queen King closer and now you're
threatened checkmate with Queen to be it
and there is a really no good way to
stop it
you have to prolong it with Bishop to f4
but okay Queen captures and now after
before you are hoping to get your rook
to the B file but it doesn't help Queen
captures rook b1 but now Ruby a Czech
Knight blocks and now Queen to a3 is
checkmate as the King is preventing the
White King from from approaching from
getting away from the a file so after
this move yes Queen to b4 wins the game
for black but here black actually played
Queen to c7 check again creating more
couple complications King to a8 was
played and now comes Luke to a5 here
black thought okay it doesn't matter
maybe I miss that but I'm still gonna
checkmate you on a 7 there is no defense
against
in captures on a7 or you would think
there's not a bush of the g5 check black
has to move and you have to be very
careful do you want to capture the
bishop or do you want to move the King
moving the King can run into some very
nasty ideas after rook a1 check King
moves rook f1 check King moves and rook
to the 8 will be checkmate or okay you
could have gone to have 7 but still it
would mean severe loss of material for
black but after Bishop to g5 check black
decided to capture it rook capture son
g5 so white gives up some material to
prevent checkmate on a7 and white gets
the opportunity to bring his rooks into
the game we looked to d1 check King has
the move you can go to see it because
the knight is controlling c8 rook to e1
check King moves to the fate and now
rook comes to d7 finally the black Queen
has to move black didn't have time to go
for rook to a5 and Queen - captures on
a7 checkmate
now the Queen has to move rook captures
on h2 and now comes the other route
comes to e7 so now black has to be very
careful if you if you can play or
something like c7 c8 Queen it's all over
black black is the one getting
checkmated so we have Queen captures on
g2 pinning the c6 pawn rook to b7 now
the point is no longer pinned you can
pull the pond and also the knight is
protecting it we have ripped the c5
putting a route behind the passed pawn
but why it simply doesn't care
c7 Queen to g4 now controlling the c8
square but it doesn't help you all that
much rook to f7 check King to e8 and now
before we have rook to c2 and now a for
white simply starts pushing his other
passed pawns and black wants to do the
same with h5 we have a 5 H form there's
a race between fast pawns which which
passed pawn is the fastest b5
h3 Knight to c6 and now comes h2 and
here while a while white can do a lot of
things to end this game for example
rookie 7 check wins the game immediately
after we move the King simply rook check
Queen here and rook captures on c8 will
be
checkmate but as this was a such a crazy
game black decided to end it with even
more craziness he played rook captures
on g7 and it was in this position that
the other mr. hoody guy mister hassling
decided to resign the game as White is
basically forcing the Queen to capture
the rook and after the Queen captures
the rook you are no longer in control of
the c8 square here c8 Queen all rock is
coming and it is all over this is now a
checkmate so for those of you who
weren't counting in this game white to
come from e1 all the way to a 8 made 15
moves with his King and I also mentioned
I will say something more about this
game now seeing the comments of this
game on chess games calm people said
that this game was actually never played
that it was constructed but I don't know
as mr. Christophe Vanderloo has two
games available in the chess base both
both against mr. M hassling and one of
them is played as we've already
mentioned in 1983 in a weekend
tournament in Holland but for the other
for the other game where the caro-kann
was played it says it's not a real game
it says that it's an analysis so if this
game wasn't played if it was constructed
or if it was invented let's say and
invented in mortal why doesn't it say if
it says for the other game also
available by mr. Christophe Vanderloo in
the database that was constructed or
that it was just an analysis so perhaps
I mean there are so many of you there's
only one of me perhaps you can get to
the bottom of this storm maybe you know
something about this give me you will be
more successful in finding information
about it then I was so if you have a
feel free to share in the comments I
will either pin your comment or add your
and anything you can find about this
game in the description below so
everyone else can increase their vast
knowledge as well but yeah constructed
or not it's really an insane game I will
name it to be invented immortal until we
get to the bottom of this so I do hope
you enjoyed it really really a nice game
for a Saturday and congratulations to
all of you who solved all four pause the
videos you truly are
an excellent spender of your Saturday I
would like to thank Edgar shelf mark
Vaughan Paul may burners Polara and Liu
Mara 40 for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video so you're thank you for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting content and
hopefully I will manage to get add that
poll already so you can vote for the
Nets next series today thank you all and
I will see you soon